hi
i'm david buckles
i'm also d scott buckles
i'm also david spockles
and my friends know me as scott buckles
does your business know that
master data management is a solution
that helps us determine the single view
of a person place or thing
let's walk through an example
and show you just how important that is
to help drive
personalization and compliance with
different data regulations across the
world
i just planned my first vacation
since the pandemic started i'm super
pumped to go to an exotic location and
stay at one of my favorite hotels
it's been a long flight
got a great greeting from the bellman as
you open the door and as i pass through
the lobby
i have trepidation to know whether or
not all the requests that i've made as
part of my reservation will be made
when i booked it on the app
i requested
a high floor
traditionally
i've always asked for
fluffy pillows
and then as a super duper titanium
member i always want my
free breakfast
in order to do that
we have to be able to determine that i
am the same david buckles across each of
these
different applications
and that when the front desk
checks me in they've recognized that and
incorporated all of my different
requests
let's take a deeper look
in the mobile app
i'm david buckles from columbus ohio
because it's tied to my credit card
and that's how the reservation was
booked
in the past in the legacy
reservation system
i've booked rooms as d scott buckles
and that is where my fluffy pillow
request has always come in
i've also
had somebody with the name david
spockles from columbus georgia call in
is that me or is that a different david
buckles
stay tuned
and finally in the loyalty application
when i first signed up i lived in boston
massachusetts and i entered under just
my common name of scott buckles
mdm solutions at their core are
algorithms they take different
parameters and different rules to
determine
if
a person is the same person with
different data entry points such as
david buckles d scott david s or scott
buckles
a good mdm solution will be able to
determine
whether i am the same person across all
four of these or maybe it's just three
of the four so the moments come
i approach the front desk
and am i going to have
a great experience
or
am i going to have a not so great
experience
if your organization wants to ensure
personalization
and compliance your mdm solution has to
be able to
determine
and match
me to a single view
across multiple different data sets
on-prem in the cloud across clouds
across all your different repositories
and systems to ensure that i have that
positive experience
thanks for watching if you have any
questions please leave them in the
comments below also please remember to
like this video and subscribe to our
channel so we can continue to bring
content that matters to you
you